[Music]
as for former MCU star Gwyneth Paltrow
she arrived to court carrying a 250
notebook slash face shield to continue
what has been called a quote blissfully
ridiculous ski trial I apologize the
defense is expected to rest their case
tomorrow gwyneth's two children apple
and Moses didn't end up taking the stand
their depositions were read out loud
instead recalling Peter as a fake Moses
to the stand okay this is kind of weird
when I skied over I heard my mom yelling
at the guy something along the lines of
what the
ran into me I said you skied directly
into my back she was not going to ski
for the rest of the day but she never
does well I lost
half a day of skiing so why the switch
gwyneth's lawyer blamed scheduling
conflicts but it definitely shielded
them from becoming memes like their mama
I'm just under 5 10. okay I am so
jealous I think I'm shrinking them
[Music]
foreign